All right, everybody.
It's time for Drew's News.
Come rest your head on our fluffy good news pillow.
And with me at the desk
is the one, the only Rossy Ross Matthew.
Hi everybody.
Hi.
(audience cheering)
Oh, I'll sleep on your pillow.
I love a good pillow.
Oh yes, of course.
Makes me think of "Planes, Trains, and Automobiles."
Those aren't pillows!
I like a nice, hard, firm pillow.
Yeah, I like a nice stiff, firm pillow.
(Ross laughing)
That's what I found out about myself at 27 years old.
Okay, well, first up we have been waiting for years
for this, but it is here.
The blockbuster "Wicked" is finally being turned into
an actual movie.
(audience cheering)
Finally.
And Pop Sugar reports that rehearsals start this July
with our two brand new witches,
Cynthia Erivo and Ariana Grande.
(audience cheering)
And they say that are spending loads of time together
to build up on their sisterhood in preparation.
They play Elphaba and Glinda,
and the witches that originated it,
Idina Menzel and Kristin Chenoweth,
they made those roles famous.
The two OGs are big fans of the new witches,
and they said, may it change your lives forever
the way it had as for us.
Have you seen "Wicked"?
Have I seen "Wicked," what?
Hello?
I would no longer be able to be gay
if I hadn't seen "Wicked."
Are you kidding me?
This is one of the prerequisites.
It might have turned me gay.
I don't know.
It is so good.
If you haven't been to see "Wicked," anybody,
it is like an amazing experience.
(audience cheering)
Okay.
And just think about this movie, you guys.
I mean Cynthia Erivo, Oscar nominee,
and then Ariana Grande.
Hello?
Did you see her in "Don't Look Up" too?
I mean, she's like-
Yes.
We know her as an actress as well.
This movie is going to be hu-
I think it's gonna be very popular.
(Ross laughing)
Oh!
Oh man, I can't wait.
Can't wait.
All right, moving on.
You know, over the last couple of years,
a lot of us have spent some extra time in the kitchen
upping our cooking game.
You know, I make my Ross-ecipes here.
I cook all the time.
Yeah, you do.
Well, apparently, now home chefs like me
are feeling very confident,
and "Martha Stewart" reports,
a new survey found 63% of home cooks
said they could hold their own against a pro chef
in a cooking competition.
That's right, okay.
77% said cooking is one of their most favorite activities.
84% said the best part is having someone
say that they love it and that it tastes delicious.
Yeah, that's the, right?
There's nothing like when you make a meal for someone,
and they're like, that's so good.
Yeah, I've had the opposite reaction many times.
(audience laughing)
I have.
I actually, I'm still intimidated by it.
I am like a humble home cook.
I love food, but for years I feel like
I would serve up what I concocted and the faces were like,
you know?
But no-
It's gotten better.
Of course, I've tasted your food.
Your food's delicious, Drew.
It's gotten a lot better, but I...
It is.
Your food's delicious.
Thank you.
I still will always have a little bit of that
like, insecurity.
Yeah, see, I watched the food competition shows,
and I'm like, girl, I could do that.
I know I could.
And can I break some news right now?
Nobody knows this.
Okay, you know that,
I don't even know if I can talk about this,
but what are I gonna do, stop me?
So, you know the show "Guy's Grocery Games" with Guy Fieri?
Yes, of course.
Of course.
I love Guy Fieri.
Well, I competed on an episode of "Guy's Grocery Games"
Yes.
Oh my god!
Can you even?
Wait, when does it come out?
I think it airs in April, and I can't tell you anything.
Don't even look at my face.
Like, I'm not gonna give it away how I do.
Don't even look.
I know you.
You won.
I don't know.
I know it.
I'm gonna make a bet, and I'm gonna put some money on it,
and I don't have any on me, but metaphorically speaking,
I will take a bet and say you won.
Well, you have to wait to find out.
I don't know.
It's a lot of pressure when that clock hits time,
let me tell you.
(upbeat music)